welcome to QQ machinery and farming in
today's video we'll be looking at the
top five pieces of farm equipment every
modern farmer needs to increase
efficiency save time and boost
productivity whether you're just
starting out or looking to upgrade these
machines are essential before we get
started don't forget to subscribe and
hit the notification Bell for more
farming tips and Equipment reviews
first up is the tractor the most
versatile tool on any farm from plowing
fields to hauling heavy loads tractors
are the backbone of modern farming they
come in different sizes from compact
models perfect for small farms to larger
high-powered machines for big operations
when choosing a tractor make sure to
match its horsepower with the size and
needs of your farm remember investing in
a good tractor can save you both time
time and effort regular maintenance like
checking tire pressure and oil levels
will extend the life of your tractor
next is the combine harvester designed
to streamline the process of harvesting
grains like wheat corn and soybeans by
combining three tasks reaping threshing
and winnowing this machine dramatically
cuts down the time it takes to bring in
your crops with features like automated
steering and yield monitors today's
combines are smarter than ever making
them a crucial investment for larger
Farms some Modern combines can Harvest
up to 30 acres per hour third on the
list is the plow an essential tool for
preparing the soil plows break up and
turn over the soil helping with ation
and weed control making it easier for
crops to take root there are various
types of plows such as B board and
chisel plows each designed for specific
soil conditions for example chisel plows
are great for loosening compacted soil
without disturbing the entire surface be
sure to adjust the depth of the plow
based on your crops requirements for the
best
results fourth is the fertilizer
spreader a must for maximizing crop
yields a good spreader ensures that
nutrients are distributed evenly across
your field f s promoting healthier
growth there are two main types
broadcast spreaders which cover large
areas and drop spreaders which provide
more precise application choosing the
right type depends on your crop and
field size a well-calibrated fertilizer
spreader can reduce fertilizer waste and
boost Crop Production lastly we have
irrigation systems proper irrigation is
key to maintaining healthy crops
especially especially in regions with
inconsistent rainfall drip irrigation
systems are highly efficient delivering
water directly to the roots of plants
which saves both water and money for
larger Fields pivot irrigation systems
can cover a lot of ground and ensure
even water
distribution Pro tip installing moisture
sensors can help you track soil water
levels and avoid over or
underwatering and there you have it the
top five pieces of of farm equipment
every modern farmer needs whether it's
plowing planting fertilizing or
harvesting the right Machinery can make
all the difference in your Farm's
efficiency and productivity these tools
are investments but they will pay off in
the long run by Saving you time and
effort if you enjoyed this video or
learned something new be sure to give us
a thumbs up and subscribe for more great
farming content let us know in the
comments which piece of equipment you
use most on your farm thanks for
watching QQ machinery and farming stay
tuned for more farm equipment reviews
and tips on how to make your farm more
efficient